you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news
on today's program
the never-ending rainy season we report
from south sudan at the front line of
the climate crisis
how nuclear fusion could play a major
role in our clean energy future
and flying high around britain to tackle
the climate crisis
we speak to conservationist sasha dench
ahead of her world record challenge
[Music]
hello there and welcome to the uk's only
daily climate news show
where we track the changes that are
happening to our world
right now and meet those who are coming
up with the solutions
now south sudan is just 10 years old but
its early years have been difficult ones
a civil war only ended last year and
more than half the population
face acute food insecurity well now
climate change has become
the most pressing challenge the un says
1.6 million people
have been affected by flooding our
africa correspondent john sparks reports
from boar county
they say water is a blessing in south
sudan
but the people who live here have never
experienced
anything like this
vast areas lie underwater after two
years of unprecedented flooding
with crops and fields and homes for 200
000 covered by an inland sea
we're following the road north in the
direction of sudan
but there's very little left of the
highway some of the richest
agricultural land in the country now
used by a handful of fishermen
the majority who lived here in jungle a
state
have departed for higher ground but
there are a few stragglers left
trying to hang on the water is keeping
on increasing
it keeps increasing it keeps on
increasing this is only a problem we are
facing here
the flood waters have spread inland from
the river nile
and last year's rainy season never
stopped
the un is now trying to restore an
ageing dike
all of this area of south sudan has
changed on the map
and so they've lost vast stretches of
land and they've lost
areas of land where people were living
and farming before
many here say the flooding is part of
god's plan
but government officials say otherwise
it is when you have given up
of thinking scientifically that way you
will say is god
but to us we say it is a global warming
those who remain here eat water lilies
and fish
in a new world overwhelmed by water
john sparks sky news in south sudan
and you can see more from john's time in
broad county that's on our weekly
digital show
that will be available on sky news
social channels our app
and website from saturday morning now
for decades
nuclear fusion has been talked about as
the ultimate solution to the world's
energy needs
and by extension the climate crisis it's
a limitless source of clean energy
without any of the harmful byproducts
that produced by nuclear fission well
that's how our nuclear power is produced
today
well if it sounds too good to be true
that's because the processes involved
have always proved too complicated
for scientists to replicate at scale but
efforts continue and this week a company
backed by amazon founder jeff bezos
confirmed plans to build its first
nuclear fusion plant
here in the uk so what is nuclear fusion
all about we're here to explain more
is dr amy gandy senior lecturer in
nuclear materials engineering at the
university
of sheffield dr gandhi good to talk to
you could you just explain to us
how this works well the general concept
with fusion
is that we're trying to force really
small particles together
and when you can force these particles
together they actually fuse and when
they fuse they generate
new particles and these new particles
have an awful lot of energy associated
with them
and we can harness that energy to
generate electricity
what stops it from being scalable
well we can at the moment achieve fusion
so we can create
these fusion plasmas so this is where
we're heating our small particles
together
to ten times hotter than the sun so they
become a gas type
state called plasma and this allows them
to be affected by magnetic fields
and this means we can fuse these
particles together even though they're
really high temperatures so we can
actually achieve that even though it
sounds quite incredible
the challenge at the moment is the fact
that we have to put so much energy in
compared to how much energy we get out
so this is one of the main challenges
that all of these new reactors that are
in development that are going to be
built around the uk and around the world
are trying to solve so these are the
main challenges and if we overcome those
challenges how much of our energy do you
think it could create
well a fusion reaction if we're thinking
about it on mass by the amount of
fuel that we need can generate million
times more energy
than burning fossil fuels so it can
generate an awful lot of energy
and as you said at the beginning and it
won't produce the same levels of
radioactive waste that we have at the
moment for nuclear fission
the map the fuels that we use are
readily available so
um they are things like lithium and
things that we can get
from water so the isotopes of hydrogen
so deuterium and tritium
so they're readily available and and
obviously water is a never-ending supply
and also fusion is inherently safe
so um we can't have a runaway chain
reaction like you would with nuclear
fission the technology
is essentially completely the opposite
is a different type of physics
that's been fascinating talking to you
dr amy gandy thank you
now let's bring you some more of today's
climate news now
and it might seem strange given the
thunderstorms and the rain that we've
been seeing across the uk today
but weather warnings for extreme heat
have been launched after a
record-breaking number of
heatwave deaths were recorded in england
last summer
public health england recorded 2256
excess all-cause deaths during three
periods that are officially classed as
heat waves last summer
the highest number since its records
began in
2004.
there are worries that the un climate
summit in glasgow later this year is
headed for failure
following little progress in three weeks
of preparation discussions
one obstacle to progress is the failure
by wealthy countries
to deliver on their promise to deliver
climate finance to less developed
countries
there are also questions over whether
some country's delegates will be able to
attend cop
26 at all with many poorer nations
unable to access
vaccines after supplies were brought up
by
richer countries
now one for the fashionistas gucci has
developed a
vegan alternative to leather made with
77
plant-based materials it's named dimitra
in reference to the greek goddess of
harvest
the luxury brand's vegan leather
contains viscose and wood pulp compounds
that are sourced from sustainable
managed forests
now there are all sorts of ways to raise
awareness about climate change and one
person hoping to inspire change
is sasha dench sasha otherwise nicknamed
as the human swan
is taking on a challenge that's never
been done before
in a bid to break two guinness world
records she will attempt to fly around
the entire coast of britain
in a wind and green electric powered
paramotor
the conservationist will use the 3 000
mile journey to meet the people tackling
climate change
and prove solutions can be found through
new ideas
well the human swan sasha joins
me now uh really good to talk to you
sasha
looking at these images here it's quite
phenomenal to see you
up there in the sky in that contraption
what does it feel like to be flying with
the birds
well flying with birds is absolutely
amazing they definitely see you as
another bird in the air they quite often
will come and try and fly with you
particularly if you're firmling because
they'll look for other signs in the air
of um of where they might be updrafts so
that is incredible
but you are obviously um hanging from a
seat high up in the air so it can feel
also quite fragile
it sounds absolutely petrifying if you
ask me is it dangerous
um i've been doing it for quite a long
time the key thing is really that
the thing that flies is the the wing
part of it the motor part
just keeps you airborne um and yeah
the the nice thing is what i love about
it is that when you're in the air you
are quite like a bird because you're
very attached to the wing so
you can read exactly what the air is
doing and that's the most important
thing
and if it all goes really wrong you have
also got a spare parachute in your
pocket but
um yeah i've been doing it long enough
that um actually being up in the sky is
a happy place for me
oh well it looks tremendous and other
than wanting to break
a guinness world record you've got a
serious mission though haven't you about
climate change sasha
yeah so there's two guinness world
records one of them is me putting skin
in the game i do expeditions with
migratory birds in a normally in a
petrol-powered paramotor
and i want to see how far you can go
switching to to electric
um ditching the the fuel from there and
the second thing though
is trying to rally the whole country
around
a different idea of climate change no
longer having it as being this
dark cloud on the horizon a kind of
climate again trying to turn
into a big opportunity there are so many
great
stories great people great ideas around
the country
where people are taking the the climate
challenge head-on
and finding solutions for it and they're
from all sorts of industries they're
from you know big industry they're from
farming
they're people doing things locally and
that's what i want to spotlight i want
to see them for myself as well
i would like to to be inspired by that
and
really believe that britain drove the
industrial revolution and we really can
drive the green revolution too that's
the story i'm hoping to be able to tell
by stopping and meeting
to all these different people around the
country well sasha dench
wishing you a very safe flight we'll
keep our eyes
up to the sky perhaps we might see you
thank you thank you
now from one intrepid explorer to
another
sailor tobias carter's work takes him
all the way to the arctic
the eco adventurer has led teams on
several polar expeditions
to measure the impact of climate change
from the front line
he's hoping to raise greater awareness
of the threat facing the natural world
[Music]
i'm just a simple citizen concerned like
many about the future of our planet
discovering sailing and what's happening
to the world
i wanted to take action
[Music]
we're here to show people the impacts of
climate change
by the stories of the people the
scientists and the locals that
see these impacts first hand with our
vessel north about we also participate
in various research programs
to better anticipate and understand
climate change
we hope to convince people here in
europe that climate change is not in 50
or 100 years
is happening now
greenland is so important to the changes
affecting our climate
climate change isn't this far-fetched
idea people here
are seeing first-hand the changes
already
affecting our world
the one important thing about climate
change it's got to be
hope society is changing it doesn't
happen
overnight but it's already changing at
an incredible pace
and let's change the world together
all these wonderful adventures today
well that is it for today's show
but you can get your climate fixed still
over the weekend with our podcast on
this week's episode
we're talking to climate scientist dr
michael e mann
about his new book the new climate war
that's on climatecast
and it's available for you wherever you
normally get your podcasts from
thanks for watching hope to see you next
week